a new hideo kojima horror game has
reportedly leaked and the layers of
feared dev teases a new game as silent
hill rumors run rampant
it's a spooky day for summer
[Music]
death's training director hideo kojima's
next game is reportedly a horror title
called overdose that could feature
margaret quali who played mama in death
stranding the leak comes from tom
henderson for tryhard guides who claims
to have seen early footage of overdose
which shows actress margaret quality in
a blue dress the report said that the
footage showed quality's character
walking through a corridor with a
flashlight in third person the report
however also mentioned that it could be
played in first person as well tom
henderson for tryhard guides was clear
that it wasn't death stranding 2 which
is contrary to a slip up norman rita's
head in an interview with leo edit back
in may where he said that death
stranding 2 was just starting production
kojima responded by ordering rita's to
go to his private room but didn't deny
it either now it's no secret that kojima
is working on something recently he's
been posting pictures from mocap rooms
even more he's also been sharing photos
of margaret quality's appearances at
cans which certainly feeds into
speculation that he could be working
with the actress on something new but
still
rumors
are rumors one thing's for sure kojima
has been very vocal about wanting to
make a horror game ever since the late
and great pt the teaser for what would
have been his silent hills game so who
knows maybe this is the kojima horror
follow-up we've been waiting for
[Music]
speaking of kojima's plans for silent
hill may be lost but the silent hill
franchise continues to live on in the
rumor mill horror-centric developers
bloober team makers of layers of fear
blair witch and the medium has released
a teaser for a new project one that
alludes to a new layers of fear after
all it was posted from the layers of
fear 2 official twitter account however
that teaser comes amidst ongoing rumors
that blooper team may be working on
something silent hill related in
collaboration with konami the teaser
shows a decrepit image of a torn and
haggard painting layers of fear
surrounds the story of a painter slowly
losing their mind so it certainly seems
in line that another layers of fear is
on the way additionally bloomer
announced in october 2021 that a new
layers of fear project powered by unreal
engine 5 is coming so this may very well
be that in my opinion though it sort of
feels like we're just trying to grasp on
anything possibly pointing to a new
silent hill i don't deny that bloopers
working on something silent hill related
with konami i just think we have to wait
a little longer until we can actually
have any of that confirmed
xbox had phil spencer was caught playing
banjo-kazooie recently and the result
has fans thinking it's a tease for an
upcoming announcement for a new
banjo-kazooie according to phil
spencer's xbox activity which can be
tracked using xboxgamertag.com
p3 or phil spencer rather showed he was
playing the classic platformer just five
days ago for a total of 37 minutes just
enough time to unlock a single
achievement and also just completely rip
open everyone's hopes and expectations
furthermore he hasn't touched it since
he's just been busy playing elden ring
and ninja gaiden which
maybe banjo-kazooie was just too easy
for him he wanted a change of pace
something harder or maybe he was taking
a break from the hard games to play
something you know a little bit more
chill but who really knows maybe june
12th xbox and bethesda's showcase will
have a happy surprise for those fans
we'll have to wait and see speaking of
here at gamespot we'll be code streaming
all of summer game fest hosted alongside
devante chisholm lucy james tomorrow
hussein and myself current devina we'll
have pre and post show content to
speculate talk and get excited over the
most exciting time of the year to be a
gamer so tune in here all week at
gamespot including sunday june 12th at 9
30 a.m pacific time for the xbox and
bethesda game showcase
and lastly for the day battlefield 2042
season one is launching on june 9th and
we have hands-on preview coverage of it
on site and our youtube channel right
now so links to all that jazz in the
description below
[Music]
all right folks thanks for tuning in for
today's news sorry devonte could not be
the one to grace your presence but don't
worry you're gonna see a lot of them
this week he'll be back for news he'll
be hosting summer game fest with me
it's a time to be excited
it's the time to see devante because
devante's the cool news guy i'm just
filling it he's he's he's like a
traveling man i'm like
the not so cool devonte they got they
got to work with what they got and i i'm
what they i'm what they got anyways
that's enough all right
be well see you guys later